so some great news was announced
yesterday Medicare will be insolvent by
2026 and Social Security by 2034 so this
means of course something that we
already knew but now it makes it
official that baby boomers will be the
last to enjoy either benefit their kids
the Millennials and younger generations
are pay paying into this system
financing it but it will not be there
for us the older generations are
draining it dry and leaving nothing for
their kids that's what's happening
how else can you put it that's what's
happening there they are milking this
thing dry and and just tossing it to the
side and saying to their kids generation
well see ya
good luck yes the older generations have
been completely resistant to any
discussion of reforming or changing
these programs so that perhaps the
programs might be around for their kids
it's it's something that they won't even
let you talk about if any politician
tries to bring it up and almost none of
them do because they all lack the moral
courage to do so even though every
single one of them the politicians I
mean they all know the reality they've
known the reality of these systems
yet they have they will not speak truth
because the older generations vote and
they will vote out any politician who's
who speaks up and says hey guys you know
maybe we don't want to steal tens of
thousands of dollars from each one of
our kids and leave them with nothing I
mean maybe we don't want to do that
maybe we should think about something
reforming changing something making some
adjustments here if any politician does
that they'll just be voted out of office
now personally I would love to do away
with social security and save for my own
retirement so when I talk about these
programs being there for me I I don't
want them I I but I also don't want to
finance them for my entire working life
which will be my entire life because I'm
net not ever gonna get to retire nobody
in my generation will but I would like
for its just not to exist and then I can
save for my own retirement I don't need
the government to save for retirement
for me it's such a crazy idea such a
crazy concept
just
I remember the first time I ever learned
about social security when I was a kid
and I remember just being flabbergasted
by it like what why would the why would
you want the government to take your
money
to save it when they're not even really
saving it but even if they were sitting
why would you want that
yes and I and I continue to be
flabbergasted I have not I still to this
day it has been perpetual a perpetual
state of being flabbergasted I just like
the word flabbergasted as you can tell I
try to work it into conversation as much
as I can so I'd like to do it but what
older folks say no you can't do away
with it because we need your money now
and then I say yeah but I won't be there
for me and they say well not my problem
I'll be dead so give me your money
that's the way this is this conversation
is going so it can't be abolished can't
be changed can't be reformed and as the
last baby boomers are dying off in the
2030s and 2040s they will take Social
Security with them
now what I'm told I talked about this
yesterday a little bit on Twitter and I
was told by some baby boomers they when
I said that you know they're gonna drain
this thing dry and leave nothing for
their kids and what I was told by some
boomers is yeah you're darn right I'm
gonna drain it dry this is my money of
course I'm gonna drain it dry it's my
money
but it's not your money
that's the thing your money is God
it is gone baby gone I mean it's it's
just it is long gone I hate to tell you
and I mean it's a terrible thing to so I
Corps sympathetic it's happening to me
right now
why
you didn't pay into anything
there was it wasn't being kept in a
lockbox somewhere the government doesn't
have a giant vault somewhere where
they're keeping all the Social Security
payments and they've got each thing and
you know nice little like a bank vault
and each person has so there are
millions of little drawers or something
keeping all the money that's not the way
this goes your money is gone it has been
stolen by the government not by us we
can have anything to do with it
so this is not your money it's my money
my generations mine
we are
my generation were just starting out in
life
some of us are a little bit further
along in that regard than others
we are we don't have anywhere near the
same assets the same financial security
as you do as an older person yet we are
being tasked with financing this huge
system this huge cumbersome gigantic
failing system that will not be there
for us that's the way this is going
it is just a horrible way to do things
you've got the younger generations who
have no money and no assets and I think
I looked it up once I don't remember
exactly the statistic but the average
net worth of someone in my generation
versus the average net worth of say a
baby boomer I mean with our ad average
net worth is a third or a quarter yet
we're the ones who have to finance this
thing
you
and so it's it kind of leaves if you're
if you're a baby boomer it leaves you
with a choice you can either insist that
we keep this system going as it is now
so that you can make all you can from it
from your kids generation
knowing that it won't be there for us so
you could do that which is what
essentially we have been doing this
whole time or you can demand that some
changes and reforms be made to it you
can say I'm willing to make a sacrifice
now for my kids generation because this
is not right what we're doing
you could say no I'm not yes the money
was stolen for me it's a horrible thing
I am NOT going to demand that I be made
whole from the theft that happened to me
by stealing for my kids
so I'm going to end this cycle of theft
and deception I don't want it to
continue I'm not going to put it on my
kids
so you could say that
it is really just a shame
that I have very rarely heard an older
person say that almost all of them it
seems are going with the former choice
and saying look I don't care I just need
to get mine
which brings me to a point that I want
to make
I'll try to be as delicate as I can here
all of this complaining that people do
about the millennial generation
calling it entitled and spoiled and
selfish and lazy I just
I just don't see how the older
generations especially baby boomers can
accuse other people of those sins with a
straight face
let's review okay the baby-boomers
inherited a prosperous country from
their parents their parents who won
world war ii and did all those great
things so they inherited a prosperous
country from them they leave behind a
bankrupted country drowning in debt they
inherited a culture with strong nuclear
families they leave behind a legacy of
divorce and broken families and they in
fact were so terrible at marriage that
their kids have given up on marriage
almost entirely they inherited
relatively strong churches they leave
behind empty decaying churches and we
can go right down the list looking at
things politically and socially I mean
think about politically think about all
the baby boomers baby boomer politicians
has there been a good one that's almost
the worst thing about well it's not the
worst thing the worst thing is the
destruction wrought upon the family by
the boomers but still politically
whether you're looking at politically
socially culturally we find that the
boomers just absolutely decimated
everything
so
it as the kind of their last and final
act that kind of drain Social Security
dry and leave nothing for their kids you
know
so our Millennials entitled in selfish
yeah many are
but where do you think they learned it
from
where do you think they picked up the
habit
where did they learn it from they
learned it from the best clearly
they were they were they were tutored
they were under the tutelage of their
parents generation
and now the worst thing about the
millennial generation is that they're
ending up exactly like their parents
they learned it to be specific from
divorced parents
in front of televisions for their entire
childhood let the media and Hollywood
raise their kids so that they could run
out and amass material wealth for
themselves at the expenses of their
families and their marriages
that's where they learned it and now
these very same people who have been
selfish and entitled their entire lives
and are leaving behind destruction and
ruin from everywhere they went have the
audacity the gumption to sit back
enjoying a retirement that we will never
experience on a pension we will never
have with Social Security checks that we
will never see and complain about the
kids that they screwed up
it's incredible it's such an incredible
dynamic that we're seeing play out how
do we let them get away with it how do
we ever let a boomer complain about
anyone let alone their own kids
who are turning out exactly like them
maybe you have these people who didn't
even bother to raise their own kids and
are now shocked when they see how their
kids are behaving
you
now whenever I point out the cataclysmic
awfulness of the boomer generation
I am
and I mean I cataclysmic I don't know
how else to describe it especially when
you look at what they did to the family
into marriage but whenever I point this
out I'm scolded for generalized and for
being divisive and for engaging in
generational warfare and all that
now funnily enough those very same
people who who tell me I shouldn't
criticize entire generations they would
they never complain when I criticize
Millennials which I do all the time I
criticize my own generation all the time
and I'm quite unforgiving in those
criticisms of my peers and of myself and
whenever I do that I never hear these
people say well you know that's unfair
you shouldn't lump an entire generation
together no they don't say it then they
only say it when you talk about their
generation so again we see the Boomers
expecting special treatment which is in
keeping with how they've always operated
now and I know this obviously does not
apply to every boomer it doesn't apply
to my own parents hopefully if you're a
boom are watching this it does or listen
to this it doesn't apply to you
although
although I don't know if it does or not
but I mean only you know but if you know
it doesn't apply to you then there's no
reason to be offended by anything that
I'm saying I'm sure in that case you
agree with me because just like when
when people criticize the Millennial
Generation III you generally agree with
those criticisms and I say so
but it's clear that the boomer
generation as a whole has been horrific
ly historically terrible and I do
believe that's important to point out
for two reasons number one it's just a
matter of being honest and just you know
I can't sit here and allow all the
problems in our society to be foisted by
the people who cause the problems onto
my generation I just can't I can't
tolerate that it's not right it's not
just it's not honest
and so I think in the interest of being
honest
it's important to point this out
and I really I just I'm sorry I don't
have a lot of sympathy for boomers who
mine when their generation is criticized
howdy Millennials are criticized off by
everywhere all the time constantly our
whole lives is I mean this is
everything's been all the problems in
society have been put on our shoulders
from like from birth for goodness sakes
and now you can't handle it when you're
criticized a little bit I mean cry me a
river
second if we're ever going to break this
cycle we have to understand where these
problems come from and what caused them
to put to put all the blame on
Millennials it's not just unjust and
dishonest but it also precludes us from
actually ever solving any problems
because we're ignoring the origin of the
problems
and where is the origin where can you
find the origin well as always it goes
back to the family it goes back to the
home baby boomers speaking generally
okay and it's not true of every single
one individually as I've already said a
million times now but baby boomers were
very very bad at marriage and very very
bad at parenting and I I feel that's the
statistics back me up on that I mean
look at the divorce rate especially look
at the divorce rate in like the late 80s
early 90s when or really throughout the
80s into the early nineties look at the
divorce rate when the boomer generation
was in kind of crime
marrying years look at the divorce rate
it is just astronomically high
it shot through the roof
with the boomer generation so when I say
they were bad at marriage I mean that's
an understatement I'm being very kind
putting it that way
and if you're bad at marriage you're
going to be bad at parenting
um how do we reverse this trend as
Millennials we've got to be able to look
at it be honest about it so that we can
reverse that have some chance of
reversing the trend what we reverse it
by shifting our focus by putting our
priorities where they belong
in the home with our families we form
stable fan families we remain loyal to
them we reject materialism selfishness
greed secularism all of these things
that our parents generation embraced we
have to reject we have to build our
families on something stronger than that
that's our only hope that's our hope of
really making the change and I mean I
don't have a lot of hope that it will
actually happen because I look at my own
generation and for the most part most of
us seem to be repeating the same
mistakes as our parents and that's not
the case across the board there there
are pockets of Millennials in America
who are really rebelling against the
rebellion of their parents generation
our parents generation rebelled with
drugs and sex and and and orgies and
STDs okay that's how our that's how our
parents generation rebelled if we're
going to rebel against them which we
must and we should we rebel with a Bible
and
by getting married and having kids
and staying loyal to our families and
praying with our families and going to
church that's how we rebel
and there are some some millennial
rebels like that
but I think unfortunately those pockets
are few and far between where you find
them though is a wonderful thing and you
see the hope of tomorrow in those places
I pointed out before that in almost
every case the the best churches that
I've been to the churches that are on
fire with the faith are really Orthodox
and reverent and really love the faith
and truth and are engaging the culture
and engaging these talking about these
issues that need to be talked about and
are really fighting you know where you
can go and really find the church
militant people that are militant about
their faith in almost every case those
are young churches
and most of the time lead
by younger men
and in most every case mature
go to that are just
Arar
just shallow and flimsy and secular and
pathetic and weak in almost every case
those are older churches populated by
and led by boomers and that's not a
coincidence
so that shows you that shows you that
there that there are some Millennials
who are who have learned the right
lessons and are trying to apply them I
just don't know if there are enough
in any case and we fight by looking at
the mistakes that were made looking at
looking where people went off course
and then going in the other direction
it's just that
we're going to have to do that without
the benefit of Social Security or
retirement
or anything like that
but that's the way it goes no sense of
complaining about it thanks for watching
thanks for listening everybody Godspeed